let's talk about Aussie sex like
Australian sex
gobby gobby ho the elf and Harry Potter
I wanna go be God makes me think mouth
which makes me think [ __ ] you got it
I would never use the word go e ah it's
a great word like oh yeah I just got a
gobby yeah after you give me the go boom
and stick it in the classroom oh this
sounds like a whole plan yeah like it
sounds like an instrument
yeah like clack clack clack I don't you
have to go first cuz I'm thinking really
hard maybe it's cuz it's the sound it
makes
oh yeah like white white white white
black ah put it in youth black up the
John anus I'm just thinking about this
on brown eyed girl yeah brownie eye
brown eye yeah like you're you pull
apart your cheeks and you show someone
your behold visualize what is I looks
like and then brown comes out it's gotta
be a butthole it's what you do in your
at a house party not me you know others
when you're at a house party and they're
like cars driving by
you might chuck a brown eye hmm
hard to get sexy with doodle could be a
dick better be a penis dig deep
but for children so generally I still
say doodle for children crack a fat
cracker fat I'm just gonna crack a fat
sit anal sex that sounds like
masturbating to me cross-eyed some
people call a hard-on it chubby so that
kind of crack it's like you know I
snapped into fat penis mode that means
bar nah I'm just cracking a fat thinking
about this would it's great I do think
it'd be hilarious to be on tinder in
Australia after this vocabulary lesson I
think that would be really funny ha ha
ha I like that what I'm gonna say that
now Thank You Australia thank you guys
are cool people you got fun accents and
kangaroos are pretty cute adorable and
horny as [ __ ]
you